who P22 Requiem for a wildcat thousands
of people gathered recently in Los
Angeles to celebrate the Life and Legacy
of P22 the charismatic cougar whose
wanderings gained him a global following
so we did this as a way for the
community of LA but also the world to be
able to kind of grieve together for 10
years P22 roamed the Wilds of Griffith
Park next to downtown L.A
the Puma posed in photos caught by
Wildlife cameras his presence brought a
note of Nature's Wild Beauty to the
concrete and steel of the sprawling
megalopolis when he would go across the
camera and and
he he had an error of of of of uh of
confidence of of almost being Regal late
last year P22 killed a chihuahua in
Hollywood Hills and mauled another
authorities concluded he posed a danger
to humans and captured him veterinarians
discovered p-22 had injuries from
encounters with cars he was euthanized
to end his suffering p-22's mortal
remains are the subject of a dispute
between the LA area's Native American
tongva people who want to give the cat a
ceremonial burial and scientists who
want to study his body a tongva
spokeswoman told Al Jazeera the tribe is
confident p-22's remains will be handed
over to the tribe by the city's Natural
History Museum like many La Stars P22
was born in less glamorous surroundings
somewhere in the woods up north possibly
drawn by the bright lights of the big
city but more likely by the urge to find
a mate P22 traveled south
to reach La P22 somehow managed to cross
this busy eight-lane highway researchers
say around 70 big cats are killed on
California highways every year to reduce
the number of those deaths and inspired
in part by p-22's Epic Journey
California is building this giant
Wildlife Crossing it will provide safe
passage for Animals of all kinds from
one Natural Area to another the 87
million dollar span stitches together
wildlands fragmented by development even
as P22 is mourned the good news for
mountain lions and the people who admire
them is that their population is
increasing and they are heading east one
was cited last year in Central Illinois
experts say there is plenty of habitat
suitable for them in the northeastern
and Middle Atlantic regions of the U.S
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los Angeles